dieses Sushi habe ich nicht bestellt
sondern komplett selbst gemacht und ich
sage euch so viel es war ein weiter Weg
Sushi ist eines dieser Gerichte wo ich
gar nicht auf die Idee kommen würde
selbst zu machen bis heute ich habe es
zwar schon mal mehr schlecht als recht
gemacht aber heute machen wir das ganze
richtig mit freundlicher Unterstützung
von shoppingfight dazu aber später mehr
und dafür brauchen wir eine ganze Menge
Zutaten aber wir fangen an mit dem Reis
ganz wichtig ist dass wir kurz körnigen
Sushi Reis benutzen sonst funktioniert
das ganze nicht ich habe hier ein
richtig schön und der sieht alleine
schon richtig special aus ich glaube wir
sind damit auf einem guten Weg denn wenn
wir darüber nachdenken ist Sushi 90%
Reis das wichtigste bei jeder
Zubereitung von Reis ist ihm gut zu
waschen damit die überschüssige Stärke
davon losgelöst wird einfach ordentlich
Wasser hineingeben so dass er gerade
bedeckt ist einmal schön durchwaschen
unser Sushi Reis ist fertig gewaschen
wenn wir ihn durch das Wasser durch
sehen können er muss nicht perfekt
transparent sein so leicht milchig darf
es noch sein aber man muss ihn eben
durchsehen kann dann schütten wir das
restliche Wasser ab und ich sicher das
wirklich alles Wasser raus ist so dass
wir das perfekte Verhältnis von Wasser
zu Reis im Reiskocher haben und dieses
Verhältnis ist ein Volumenanteil Reis
und ein Anteil Wasser jetzt brauchen wir
den Reiskocher ganz ehrlich Leute ich
würde es mir nicht selbst zutrauen bei
sowas wie Sushi wenn ich wirklich ein
perfektes Sushi machen will den Topf zu
benutzen weil ein Reiskocher macht das
Ding an lehn dich zurück Reis
hineingeben wir sind auf Reis und jetzt
auf Sushi und jetzt schmeißen wir das
Ding einfach an und hoffen dass die
Technik uns nicht im Stich lässt zuletzt
kommt noch eine besondere Zutat hinzu
und zwar Kombo das hier ist eine Combo
Alge die gehen wir einfach noch mit rein
in den Reiskocher die quillt auch und
gibt dem ganzen den wirklich
authentischen Geschmack unser Reis
sollte jetzt fertig gekocht sein WoW und
er sieht schon richtig schön und luftig
aus unsere Combo Alge die nehmen jetzt
auch wieder raus ist auch schön
rehydriert worden noch ist das Ganze
aber kein Sushi Reis sondern nur kurz
Königreich damit es Sushi Reis wird
müssen wir es erstmal würzen und das
macht man mit Sushi Reisessig den gebe
ich in einen Topf das waren zwei
Esslöffel dazu ein Teelöffel Zucker und
ein Teelöffel Salz bei moderater Hitze
lasse ich das jetzt erwärmen und rühre
dabei einfach ein bisschen um so dass
unser Zucker und unser Salz sich
auflösen jetzt wo das ganze aufgelöst
ist nehme ich mein Reis und gebe ihn
Kopf über in eine Schale nicht in
irgendeine sondern in die Blockade zack
Reiskocher lasse ich an denn wir
brauchen gleich die Warmhaltefunktion
das ist hier mein Reis drin und ich
nehme einen Sushi reislöffel tut auch
normaler Holzlöffel und schütte quasi
auf die Rückseite meine Mischung drauf
so dass sie sich über dem Reis schön
verteilen kann und jetzt streiche ich
hier so ein bisschen durch um den Reis
aufzulockern und das Ganze zu würzen und
durch zu mischen hierbei geht's nicht
nur darum dass man das ganze wird
sondern auch dass man quasi die Körner
ein bisschen auflockert so dass sie
wieder schön einzeln für sich stehen
restliche Würzung noch dazu jetzt wird
Zeit für die Geschmacksprobe
wow perfektes Level von Essig bisschen
salzig kalt und eine leichte Süße wenn
unser Reis ein bisschen die Mischung
absorbieren konnte gebe ich ihn wieder
zurück in den Reiskocher der noch auf
der warmhaltestufe ist so bleibt unser
Sushi Reis jetzt warm kümmern wir uns um
unsere Toppings Freunde jetzt geht's an
die Wurst oder besser gesagt an den
Fisch denn wir haben vier Aufgaben für
den heutigen Tag wir machen einmal Marki
einmal Sashimi einmal Nigiri und zu
guter Letzt eine Special inside outrolle
sollen wir das Beste aus beiden Welten
aus dem japanischen Sushi und dem
amerikanisierten Sushi vieles davon
mache ich zum ersten Mal aber seid euch
sicher ich habe mich gut darauf
vorbereitet so wie auch damals als ich
meine eigene Marke Block gegründet habe
bei Blog mussten wir alles von Grund auf
neu machen die richtige Produktion
finden die Marke anmelden die Firma
gründen und natürlich den richtigen Shop
programmieren oft haben wir
zugegebenermaßen noch ein bisschen
gezweifelt ob wir das alles fertig
bekommen aber wir haben die Idee glaubt
und nicht aufgegeben ich selbst hatte
schon immer von einer eigenen kochmarke
geträumt und bin sehr fro dieses Projekt
letztendlich umgesetzt zu haben und als
wir den Shop gelauncht haben war mir
klar es gibt keinen besseren Anbieter
als shopify und umso stolzer bin ich
heute sagen zu können dass die Partner
dieses Videos sind shopify bietet eine
all-in-one-plattform bei der jeder
seinen eigenen Shop erstellen kann ganz
einfach über die App oder am Desktop
Shop unterstützt Unternehmen vom ersten
Verkauf bis hin zum großen Erfolg und
stellen die Ressourcen zur Verfügung die
sonst eigentlich nur großen Unternehmen
zur Verfügung stand ihr könnt super easy
euer Lieblingsdesign aus den vielen
eigenen Teams auswählen und direkt
loslegen die Seite selbst ist auch
unglaublich einfach aufgebaut und ihr
könnt alles frei anpassen so wie es auch
bei blog.shop gemacht habe wenn ihr
etwas verkauft erhaltet ihr eine
Benachrichtigung direkt auf euer Handy
ihr könnt die Statistiken verfolgen und
habe alles immer im Blick wenn Du also
eine eigene Marke gründen willst oder
irgendetwas online verkaufen möchtest
dann ist shopify das beste Tool für dich
mit meinem Link in der Videobeschreibung
könnt ihr das ganze kostenlos testen und
der Weg zum eigenen Unternehmen ist
nicht mehr weiter vielen Dank an shopify
fürs unterstützen dieses Videos ich
würde sagen wir machen uns ans Rollen
ich würde sagen wir beginnen mit einem
meiner allzeit Klassiker mit Lachs
Avocado Maki dafür brauchen wir Avocado
die schneide ich mir einfach einmal hier
in der Hälfte dafür Viertel ich die
Avocado erstmal sollte nicht zu weich
aber auch nicht überreift sein also wir
brauchen jetzt noch relativ
dickes leises so würde ich sagen magst
du dass wir die etwa auf die Dicke von
unseren späteren Lachsfilets bekommen
ihr wisst Leute ich bin bei sowas auch
ehrgeizig ich wäre am Ende des Tages
will ich eigentlich ein Sushi das
mindestens so gut ist wie wenn ich mir
beim Sushi Lieferservice bestellen
Avocados geschnitten jetzt wird's
richtig spannend Messer sauber machen
Lachs Magie Papier ein Abschnitt von
unserem Lachsfilet die wir auch noch
durch den dünnen Part ziemlich gut
zusammenlegen können dass wir gleich
eine durchgängige Marke Rolle machen
können wir brauchen unsere Nori Blätter
die kann man entweder in dieser Größe
kaufen oder bereits halbiert der Marke
nimmt man die halbierten man kann aber
auch die großen einfach selbst halbieren
selbst überlassen jetzt nehmen wir unser
Platz legen es einmal hin und jetzt
brauchen wir eine schöne Handvoll von
unserem Sushi Reis nehme jetzt einen
kleinen Tropfen Öl in die Handfläche und
verreibe das einfach an meinen
Handschuhen so und jetzt nehme ich mit
meinen geölten Handschuhen ein bisschen
Sushi Reis raus Formen den hier einmal
zu einer Kugel der Trick scheint zu
funktionieren das klebt nichts an den
Händen jetzt nehme ich mir meinen Sushi
Reis und jetzt ist der Trick ihn erstmal
der Breite nach ein bisschen
auszubreiten ein bisschen mehr hier an
die Seite ihr seht es hier ist mein Nori
Blatt gerissen das ist ein bisschen
ungünstig zweiter Versuch nehmen wir
unsere Sushi Matte so hier oben habe ich
probiert ein bisschen höher zu lassen so
dass wir jetzt dahinter unsere Zutaten
für die Marke legen können einmal Lachs
Avocado es ist relativ viel stuff drin
man hält dabei so die Zutaten fest und
drückt sie unten gegen diesen kleinen
Damm aus Reis den wir gemacht haben so
irgendwie würde man das schaffen weil
wir wollen ja diese Folge ist irgendwie
geht bekommen nichts
Leute
das ist mit Sicherheit sehr lecker
nächster Versuch
dritter Versuch nehmen wir uns unsere
Matte legen sie nieder ein Nori Blatt
darauf jetzt habe ich auch langsam die
Routine die ich brauche und jetzt
bereite ich meine Zutaten noch mal
besser vor so dass es nicht zu viel wird
so und jetzt klappen wir das Ganze zu
halten die Zutaten drin bisschen mit
Wasser drüber einmal überklappen noch
und jetzt sollten wir ein bisschen Glück
eine vernünftige Markierung fast im Takt
da müssen wir gucken dass wir sie gleich
schneiden bisschen tricksen jetzt kommt
der große Moment jetzt kommt das
Schneiden wo alles was wir bisher
geschafft haben einfach noch kaputt
gehen kann vorsichtig das Messer
durchgleiten lassen nicht mit Druck
arbeiten okay
ich werde
sehr gut das erste Bestandteil steht
schon mal Leute ohne Witz wenn ich mir
das so angucke gerade mit dem Trick für
die Höhe wenn ich damit schon zufrieden
ich meine das ist ja oder weniger mein
erstes Mal dass ich die Sushi mache und
mach mir ein bisschen weiter und finden
einfach mal den Spaß an der Sache ich
mache gut machen
[Musik]
sitzen als nächstes kümmern wir uns um
Sashimi und Nigiri hier habe ich ein
schönes Stück Lachs bei welchem ich mir
angeguckt habe dass man anscheinend sehr
Chemie schneidet indem man einfach ein
zwei Millimeter über der Schnittkante
ansetzt mit den Fingerspitzen
stabilisiert und dann mit ganz ganz
wenig Druck sein Messer durchziehen das
Stück das sieht gut aus dicker das sieht
wirklich nicht schlecht aus ne und jetzt
habe ich hier gerade so ein zwei Löcher
drin dann zerfällt ne das muss auch
Essen einfach ne
ein bisschen komisch so rohen Fisch zu
essen aber es ist super Sashimi Qualität
also eine Qualität bei der man sicher
sein kann dass da alles passt und unser
Chemie nehmen wir einmal und legen es
jetzt vorne bereit langsam kommt die
Platte zusammen Ich sage euch ganz
ehrlich es ist schon ein bisschen
schneller wenn man einfach bei der
liefer-app des Vertrauens auf Chemie
klickt und das nach Hause geliefert wird
als nächstes kümmern wir uns um die
Nigiri dafür nehme ich mir wieder ein
wenig von unserem Sushi Reis den ich
einfach in der Hand zu einem schönen
Schiffchen vorne es kommt zum ersten Mal
ein wenig Wasabi zum Einsatz streichen
das jetzt auf die Seite auf die jetzt
unser Lachs oben drauf kommen die können
sich sehen lassen Danke schön danke
schön ich habe doch für irgendwas
mit unserem Thunfisch auch hier schaffen
wir erstmal wieder eine schöne
Schnittkante diese breite glaube ich
doch doch das funktioniert besser als
mit dem Lachs sehr gut weil der
Thunfisch einfach ein bisschen fest da
ist auch hier kommt wieder ein wenig
Wasabi drunter fertig sind unsere
Thunfisch nicht eine Sache
noch auf unserer Platte und zwar die
Inside Out special Roll in der wir alles
was ihr hier seht verwenden die Dinger
kosten locker mal 12 13 14 Euro beim
Sushi Lieferservice und wir machen uns
jetzt einfach selbst tragt besser nicht
wie viel das alles hier zusammen
gekostet hat weil dann machst du
überhaupt keinen Sinn nehmen wir uns
ordentlich Reis viel mehr als bei den
Maki und dann verteilen wir auf unserer
gesamten Nori Oberfläche alles schön
voll machen das Ganze nur Blatt muss
voll sein jetzt kommt auf die Oberfläche
weißer Sesam sowie schwarzer Sesam
und jetzt drehen wir das ganze so wie es
ist einfach auf die Oberseite deshalb
Inside Out eine ordentliche Schicht cupy
Mario in die Mitte jetzt kommt unser
Lachs einmal rein unsere Avocado und
jetzt machen wir zu den Apparat
zusammendrücken und überrollen das ganze
direkt schön in Form bringen klassische
rechteckige und ja es sieht nicht
verkehrt aus oder nein wir haben hier so
ein zwei blindspots da fühle ich mal ein
bisschen nach guck mal ordentlich Druck
drauf von den Seiten noch mal ein
bisschen nachformen da haben die halbe
Miete jetzt Leute komm sehr schön
die einmal und Topf unser Lachs das
schön jetzt kann man wirklich kreativ
sein Mango drüber aber jetzt würde sich
wiederum ein wenig Thunfisch gut machen
so falls euch jetzt fragt was hat dieser
Mann gerade fabriziert wenn ich mich
nicht irre habe ich genau den richtigen
Trick ich habe mir ein bisschen
Klarsichtfolie vorbereitet
legen wir einmal oben drauf jetzt nehmen
wir eine Rollmatte am besten nicht die
mit Klarsichtfolie weil sonst klebt ihr
gleich alles zusammen drücken das Ganze
einmal schön in Form aha so sieht es
auch schon direkt viel besser aus und
ein Trick den ich gesehen habe ist dass
man das ganze jetzt mit der
Klarsichtfolie schneidet jetzt das ganze
noch ein letztes Mal nachformen das ist
wieder schön in Form kommt und am besten
gleich mit der Klarsichtfolie abheben oh
das war so ein guter Trick ein Glück hat
das funktioniert ist trotzdem noch eine
Challenge
irgendwie rüber kriegen aber wegen dem
Platz brauchen wir dafür go das ist
Kunst Digger das ist so eine Kunst es
sieht schon es sieht schon gut aus aber
es sieht nicht so aus wie ein Restaurant
Sushi ist halt meistersache das hier ist
meine Version das erste Mal dass ich
wirklich frei hat versucht habe Sushi zu
machen so sieht's aus und
ich glaube wir sollten uns erstmal vom
Geschmack überzeugen
[Musik]
ich habe das ganze hier wie es hier
steht mal beim Sushi Restaurant meiner
Wahl in Lieferservice eingegeben und wir
sind hierbei rausgekommen 58 Euro und 60
Cent vor dem Hintergrund finde ich noch
ein bisschen mehr stolz habe ich nämlich
einfach selbst gemacht so Leute womit
fangen wir an ich würde sagen ganz
klassisch mit meinem Go2 mit dem sieht
gut aus Saga Avocado Maki also Lachs
Avocado Maki
ohne Witz sehr sehr geil Avocado darin
ist cremig der Lachs ist frisch
absolut konkurrenzfähig mit dem Sushi
Lieferservice es ist die Optik vor allem
was jetzt bei den Markisen sich
unterscheidet wobei wir hier und das
muss ich sagen da bin ich auch ein
bisschen stolz drauf schon echt auch ein
gutes optisches Resultat erzählt haben
knackige Gurke cremiger Frischkäse die
Dinger kosten pro Stück 2,80 € bei dem
Sushi Lieferservice da kriegt man zwar
auch ähnlich viel Fisch aber guckt euch
mal an wie das hier alles perfekt
zusammenhält ich kann das in meinem
Stäbchen halten bewegen schön mit der
fischseite in die Sojasoße und reiner
das ist krank wisst gar nicht wie krank
das Wasser im Mund zusammen läuft Digger
eric hat bis 14 Uhr intervallfasten
gemacht deshalb werde ich dich jetzt mal
mit dem verbleibenden lachsnigiri
füttern Bro diese Wasabi Note die dann
danach durchkommt krank auch hier sehen
wir so wenn man es gegens Licht hält das
scheint schon fast ein bisschen durch
ein Stück Special mit Mango Fischrogen
obendrauf
ohne Witz besser als Sushi ist nur Sushi
mit Mango ich liebe diese süße das mit
reinbringen der Querschnitt davon oben
drauf die Rogen das ist schon wirklich
fucking nice wieder mal gelernt das mit
genug Vorbereitung wirklich alles
möglich ist das beweisen mir oft hier
auf dem Channel ne ja und wir beweisen
sich nur auf dem Channel sondern Beweise
ist auch uns selbst weil ja gestern
waren wir so sind wir ready um dieses
Sushi zu machen fast aufgegeben wir
wollen uns eigentlich nicht machen wir
brauchen einen Sushi Meister der uns
Tipps gibt oder so aber hier ist es
geschafft Service einfach selbst gemacht
einfach herzlichen Dank nochmal an
shopify dass sie dieses Video hier
unterstützt haben es war wirklich ein
anspruchsvoll und in vielerlei Hinsicht
besonderes Video ich hoffe ihr hattet
Spaß falls ihr auch macht dann täglich
auf jeden Fall darauf und ansonsten
würde ich sagen sehen wir uns beim
nächsten Video wieder macht's gut bis
dahin ciao